so at the end of the day is spiritual
unification I feel like I've gone
through a lot of different stuff I've
had a lot of different experiences where
I did not value myself so I never had a
man that valued me so it's like yeah you
rack up guys and guys you shouldn't be
texting back or whatever but I feel like
they're I understand that there is a
difference with how men view sex and how
they move around in the world but it's
like sex is a sacred thing no matter
male or female is doing it so that's why
for me like my biggest like the hardest
for me to understand is like this is
such a a sacred thing and it's just
being it's like taking a piss for a guy